Let's learn a little bit about
centripetal acceleration.
So let's say I have a dot.
It could be anything.
And we're in deep space, so
we're not going to think about
gravity and all these
things yet.
Let's say I have some object
that's floating through space
with some velocity.
Let me draw the object.
It's this dot.
And it has some velocity.
And I will draw its
velocity vector.
Let's say that this is-- I'll
draw this really big.
That's not big.
Let me make a thicker line.
There you go.
Thicker line.
If you can see that.
So let's say that's the
dot's velocity vector.
And I have a question for you.
So this is what the dot's doing
at exactly this moment.
Let's say a little bit later,
I want the dot to be doing
something like this.
I want its velocity vector
to look like-- i want its
velocity factor to
look like this.
A little bit later.
And its color changes
to yellow.
That's out of the scope.
Color changing is out of the
scope of this lecture.
But let's say a little bit
later I want its velocity
vector to look something
like that.
So I was a little careful,
because I want it to have the
same magnitude, but just a
little different direction.
I want it to tilt into the
right a little bit.
Let me draw that.
And my question is, what had to
be the acceleration acting,
when this was its velocity
vector, in order to get its
velocity vector to look like
this a little bit later?
Well, right here, its
velocity vector is
completely in the x direction.
And there's no y component.
Let's break down this
velocity vector
into the x and y component.
So its x component looks
something like this.
And its y component looks
So in order to change its
velocity, something would have
to-- Because clearly here
its y component was 0.
There's no y component.
And now there is
a y component.
So the acceleration that you
would have to apply to this
dot would have to have
some y component.
The acceleration would have
to have some y component.
Let's say that.
This is acceleration, that's
why it's not the same size.
Actually let me draw
acceleration
in a different color.
And I'll try to do this in a
bunch of different ways, so
that you get an intuition
for it.
I'm doing it in a slightly
different blue.
So you have to accelerate in the
y direction a bit, and we
don't know how long, but long
enough to get its velocity in
the y direction this big.
And then what would you have to
accelerate in the x direction?
Well, your x component
shrinks a little bit.
This was its x component, and
now since you're tilted down,
you get more y and less x.
So what direction does
acceleration have to go in to
shrink the x component?
You have to go opposite.
So your acceleration is going
to go that way a little bit.
And so if you were to add these
two vectors, you would
have to accelerate something--
the acceleration vector would
look something like this.
So I'm-- And this might be a
little confusing to you, but
all I'm showing is that, I want
you to think about-- Say
an object is traveling through
space at a constant velocity,
what does the acceleration
vector have to look like in
order for that object to
curve a little bit?
So for example, if this was
the-- let me draw, let's say
this object was here.
And if we had no force on it,
it would just keep moving in
this direction.
Its path would look like this.
I'll draw the path in brown.
The path would look like this.
It would be here, and then
it would be here
a few seconds later.
It would just keep going in the
direction that it's at.
And we know that from Newton's
law, an object in motion tends
to stay in motion.
And the only way you can have a
change in velocity is if you
have some net force
and some net
acceleration on the object.
So in order for the object to
curve, in order for the
object's path to look something
like this-- so
here's the other path.
Let's say the object's
path is like this.
And let's say it
keeps curving.
The object's path
is like that.
It keeps curving.
Goes there, to there.
It's going in a curved motion.
What has to keep happening?
Well, in order for the object's
velocity to go from
this direction, in the x
direction, in order for its
velocity to go from this,
to go from this.
You have to accelerate
a little bit inwards.
We drew that right here.
You have to have an inward
acceleration.
And now its velocity-- and now
if you did nothing else, and
the object will just keep
going in this direction.
So in order to make it curve
little more, you've got to
pull in a little bit again.
So you have to have-- and then
if you don't pull in again,
it'll just keep going
in this direction.
So you got to keep pulling
inwards on it.
And I think you're starting
to get a sense of what I'm
saying, so if you want the
object to go in a circle, for
example, there has to be
constant inward force always
pulling on the object.
Because if there isn't that
constant inward-- so this is
this off white color, this
is when there's a
constant inward force.
The object's going to travel
in a circular path.
Well, what if that inward
force doesn't exist?
Let's say that inward force is
there, and then all of a
sudden when the object's here,
the inward force disappears.
Then the object's just going
to go in a straight line.
Tangent to the circular path.
And that makes more sense.
And I'll go into it
in a little bit
more detail in a second.
But if you are spinning
an object around in
a circle on a string.
And the string is providing the
inward force, and as soon
as you let go of the string,
the object goes off in a
straight line.
And so that that's what
we're talking about.
So what does this inward
acceleration has-- actually,
before I go into actually
calculating what that inward
acceleration has to be, let's
think about what happens when
that inwards acceleration
isn't enough
or if it's too much?
So I just said, if I have an--
let's say this is like the
center of our rotation.
Let's say this is where the
inward force is coming from.
Right there.
And let's say this
is my object.
Let say it's a spaceship.
That's my spaceship.
Fire coming out of it.
And actually the fire would
only go on an impulse.
Because once you have a little
fire coming out in space,
there's no wind resistance,
so it'll keep just going.
You don't have to keep-- so the
science fiction movies,
where the fire just
keeps going, that
doesn't make sense.
You would just have an impulse
of fire that would accelerate
you, and then you wouldn't have
to keep fueling the fire
in the back of the spaceship.
But anyway, maybe you realize
it already, or that's out of
the scope of this lecture, but
let's say that the object's
velocity is like that.
And I don't know, let's say this
is a planet, or it's some
kind of weird forcefield,
or something.
If this forcefield is a weak
forcefield, if this object is
moving really fast, and this
is a weak forcefield that's
always pulling in towards it,
the object's path is going to
look something like this.
It's not going to be a circle.
It's going to kind of
spiral outwards.
So that's kind of a
weak inward force.
If it's a really strong inward
force, the object's path is
going to look like this.
And I'll do that in yellow.
It's actually going
to fall in.
It's going to spiral
into the object.
And if it's just right, given
how far the object is, and
I'll give you a formula for
what just right implies.
But if the inward force is just
right, the object's going
to essentially orbit
around the subject.
It's going to go in
a perfect circle.
Its path will be like that.
So let's think about what that
inward force has to be.
And we're not going to-- well,
this could have been gravity,
this inward force, but I won't
work with gravity yet, because
gravity, actually the force
changes depending on how close
you get to it.
So I won't deal with
gravity yet.
But it could've been anything,
it's just a tractor beam.
So let's try to get an intuition
of how strong that
inward force is, and what
variables it's dependent on.
So let's say I have a let's
say this is my hand, and I
have a string.
And on that string,
I have a rock.
And my question is, if I want
this rock just spinning around
in a circle, and it'll spin
around in a perfect circle.
We've all done this before.
If I want the rock to spin
around in that circle, what
has to be the force that
I pull on this string?
Or essentially, how much does
the inward acceleration have
to be on that rock?
Let's get an intuition for
maybe what has to happen.
So think about it, if the rock
is moving, let's say that
right here, at this point,
its velocity looks
something like that.
At this point, it's velocity
looks something like this.
And then when the rock is
here, its velocity looks
something like this.
So to move from this velocity
to this velocity, if the
magnitude is really big, I'm
going to have to apply more
acceleration to change
direction.
Hopefully that makes
a little sense.
To go from this velocity
vector to
this velocity vector.
If this vector was even bigger,
if to say the vector
looked like this, it
had more magnitude.
I would have to pull inward
with even more force and
accelerate inward at an
even higher rate.
So definitely, the higher the
velocity the more I'm going to
have to pull in.
And also the higher the
velocity, the shorter the time
between this and this.
This object is moving
around in a circle.
So there's kind of two
components that are
affecting-- velocity affects
the acceleration
I need in two ways.
Well, actually I'm running out
of time, so I'll continue this
in the next video.